so good evening glad you all
the rain out there to get here
my dri some folks are probably still
swimming in my name is william you ricky
oh and i'd like to introduce you to the
communications forum i'm director of the
comparative Media Studies Program and
once upon a time this was a program that
had two heads
I still have phantom limb syndrome now
that Henry has escaped to USC landmark
legend fixture colleague dear friend
it's hard to know how to introduce Henry
and just looking in this audience I
could see so many communities that Henry
intersected with from senior house - of
course colleagues in CMS alum folks in
other departments faculty students
friends from outside the university
that's a real testament to to the reach
that Henry had and it's not just
students here at MIT it's not just the
vision that he helped to craft here at
MIT but Henry is a really key figure in
the field as well a seminal figure
probably the most sighted person of his
generation in academic terms but also
someone who's had a profound impact on
media industry and that is no small
trick to be at the top of your game in
one field the academic and be able to
even talk to the other let alone win
their respect and obviously the work in
popular culture and in fandom that Henry
has engaged in has won him yet another
group of adoring fans in the fan sector
itself again a very hard trick when
you're also respected by industry and
also respected by the Academy
Henry's 20 years here at MIT have been a
crucial of sorts it seems to me where
many of his ideas took form or ideas
that he came here with developed where
those ideas met the world so tonight
we're gonna spend some time Henry wall
that will give some some remarks he'll
open with that then we'll have a
discussion open it up to the floor and
then a special treat and it involves dr.
Seuss and I think something that only
Henry and MIT can do in tandem first
just a couple of announcements one as
you can see up there CMS the program
that Henry founded is having its
anniversary this is a warm-up is too
weak a word this is kind of a getting
off to a bang
I think out of the lobby when you're
done there's a hot off the presses
copy of our newsletter but it's the 10th
anniversary edition and in some ways in
a lot of ways some work sort of
summarizes the the work that we've done
that our students have done that our
researchers have done here in CMS over
the last decade it's a really don't miss
it it's a it's a terrific issue and
tomorrow pretty much all day starting
with opening remarks from our Dean
Deborah Fitzgerald at 10 o'clock in the
new Media Lab top floor 6th floor we'll
be spending a day sort of looking at
CMS's impact in the world talking with
our alum some of our researchers and
faculty across the spectrum of themes if
you go to the website you'll get the
details and please try to come to that
it should be a fun day and a really
illuminating day and the day will end
with the party at 7 p.m. same space up
there on the 6th of the new media lab
before turning the floor over to Henry
I'd like to read a letter that David
Thorburn the director of the
communications forums sent in since he's
the director and since he's probably
watching or listening
I can't dodge this bullet so I'm going
to read it not that I want to David
David's in Amsterdam right now as a as a
visiting scholar and couldn't come in so
David I deeply regret not being here for
this tribute to Henry and for his and
for this celebration of CMS I'm still
having difficulty imagining an MIT
without Henry Jenkins from the moment
the literature faculty set a precedent
by hiring this unconventional media
scholar with degrees in journalism and
film I felt we were on a course to
boldly go where no English department
had ever gone before
Henry's achievements over two decades at
MIT as the visionary founding director
of CMS and as a media scholar more than
confirmed this expectation of course but
his immense contributions to the
Institute were not limited to these
stellar accomplishments I think I will
most treasure in memory and most deeply
miss to other Henry's the charismatic
teacher whose classrooms were fiery
exhilarating places of intellectual
discovery and housemaster Henry who in
partnership with his gifted and
long-suffering Cynthia
Cedar's let's seen your house so
generously and intelligently despite
continuing abject performances at
wrestling competitions during the annual
statement steer host thinking across a
range of Henry's writings and teaching
is a daunting experience for most of us
since he handles so many topics and
cultural forms with such commanding
authority but there are through lines in
even the most disparate of Henry's
writings and research projects I hope
today's forum will help identify this
complicated coherence which begins in
part I believe in Henry's fierce loyalty
to the aesthetic experiences and culture
of his childhood and to his respect for
the intelligence and creativity of
children gamers fans fan communities
movie goers and so many others without
credentials or official standing will
never replace Henry Jenkins at MIT but
as these next two days of celebration
and commemoration will demonstrate he
leaves enduring achievements behind CMS
will continue and extend his legacy and
let us be consoled as well by the
expectation that he will return to MIT
and I hope to the communications forum
for many conversations in the future so
without further delay I'd like to
introduce Henry Provost's professor of
communication journalism and the
cinematic arts at USC and read the floor
is yours
I hate this place I hate this
place right this is this is an
expression that has a deep history in
the undergraduate culture of MIT going
back how many decades I don't know it's
as expression that I've heard on your
graduates present with a mixture of
masochistic pleasure pain and pride
right it's a phrase we etch on our on
our chests as a tattoo to wear it to the
world and it's a phrase that is scarred
on our bodies and our brains by our
experiences of going through the
crucible that is MIT when I thought when
I was getting ready to leave senior
house for the last time last July and I
had to put my last blog together for
this place the last last phrase I put on
the end of the blog post was I HT EFP
right and that seemed to me to sum up
the moment that I was at a crossroads in
my life in terms of thinking about my
relationship to MIT as all that it is
and I'm part of what I want to talk
today is about MIT what it's meant to me
what it means to me and why that phrase
continues to be probably the most
appropriate way the signal one's love
and hate for MIT right that Alex
Chisholm who was key to creating CMS I
used to say at the end of the day to
take account if there's an everyday
there should be one new reason you love
MIT and one new reason you hate MIT and
when that tally gets off for too many
lays in a row you should leave right and
that's that's a set of calculations we
we live with as we think about what it
is to be at MIT you know I have to say I
never expected to ever end up at MIT
that I'm someone who has serious math
anxiety so it ended up at a place where
the the buildings and the majors are all
described by numbers right was part of
the weirdness to me as a humanities
person at the world's leading technical
institution my father went to Georgia
Tech my brother
went to southern tech I was a
non-technical person in the in the
family and my the the hits that I took
for science and math classes as an
undergraduate more or less knocked me
out of receiving the honors
I might have deserved for my grades in
literature and history and social
sciences I would never have survived MIT
that I lived here for 20 years says
something about the sort of flexibility
that this culture breeds and the
opportunities it created for someone who
never could have come through the door
as a student who could never wear the
brass rat but who was able to wear I
think make some contributions during my
time here so as we think I think about
that phrase I hate this place I
think about a number of places that
we're here and one of them is MIT as a
mailing address and I put it that way
because when I was trying to struggle to
decide do I belong in MIT someone what
faculty member here who I don't even
have which one it was said to me well
try it if nothing else it'll be a great
mailing address for the next place you
go and so that's the describe MIT as a
place a place to be from rather than a
place to be at
and for some faculty here I mean the
interesting thing is anyone who survives
as a faculty member at MIT for an eighth
length of time has made their peace in
one way or another with MIT and I think
if you look at the humanities faculty
who've been here the longest
you see impressions in their CVs of ways
that they have embraced or struggled
with the science and technological base
of MIT and it's reflected in the work
that you do the kinds of work that's
produced here is work that can only be
produced through MIT at the end of the
day there are some who come for whom
they are essentially expats of the Ivy
League you know sitting in the the
American Club high above the place
thinking about a civilizing mission for
the humanities and you know being
distrustful of the natives and whether
they really get the Magnificent thing
that humanities are well someone who's
lived with MIT students they get it
right I lived in the dorms at every dorm
room had book
in them right and Moe and the books that
survived when you have tight space or
books that are valued and some of them
might be comic graphic novels and some
might be science fiction and some might
be Middlemarch some of them are a
science textbook that they couldn't give
away that they had to hold on to but
there's something that it gets through
that's absolutely fundamental to the
experience of undergraduates at MIT and
so we sell ourselves and we sell this
place short if we treat it simply as a
mailing address right but also there was
a mailing address at something else
which is it's a bully pulpit that we as
MIT faculty have the opportunity to
speak to the world that I had the
experience during the time that I was
here of being pushed forward on to World
Stages
that I never would have had access to as
a humanities faculty member and any
other institution and the question we
have to ask ourselves is what do we have
to say to the world and can we say it in
a language the world can hear and those
are challenges that force us to think
about the tradition of humanities
whether it's insular or public focused
whether it's speaking to ourselves or
speaking to external audiences I know
that this Hank through to me most
powerfully when I wrote an email to some
of the faculty and students at MIT about
my experience testifying to the US
Senate after Columbine and just said
pass this along to anyone you think
might be interesting interested and over
the next 24 hours I got hundreds of
email from all over the world from
people who'd seen the letter we got we
got email from major newspapers who
wanted to reprint it and ended up in
Harper's Magazine we got letters from
technology people and game executives
from rabbis and prisoners you know there
was a whole array of messages and I even
what I may cherish I know which I
cherish the most the the the the fan
letter I got from Neil Gaiman or the fan
letter I got from Brian Eno right but
both of them sort of said all right we
now have this we have your attention we
have the potential the communication
forum is very much part of this and
David Thor burns leadership of the
communication forum through the years
has made this a place where industry
journalists activists artists academics
can sit down together and conduct a
conversation that may
I had the opportunity to work with the
MacArthur Foundation to write a white
paper about the future of education they
really grew out of what I'd observed
from the best of our students here at
MIT and if I say that I came here
expecting to leave it was what kept me
here for 20 years were the MIT students
you know and the quality of students
that you see here are unlike anything
that I've seen anywhere else that that
experience of working with the kinds of
minds at MIT attracts and I remember
when I first arrived here thinking the
difference between a traditional liberal
arts classroom where everyone grabs a
theory and rips at the shreds and bashes
heads together for for an hour and the
experience here where people grab a
theory and say you know this is a little
flawed why don't we fix this part
let's tinker with this name of the tie
end of the period the theory was
stronger and better because of the
problem-solving can-do attitude that MIT
Fosters and its students it's if MIT is
not just a mailing address it's also the
Institute which is a sort of structured
curriculum a structure of disciplines
and ways of learning and ways of
thinking that I think is built into the
concrete and you know and marvel of MIT
and the message we get so often as
humanists at MIT is that we don't belong
here right to wake up every morning and
go to work wait for the elevator and
watch some guy walking backwards sort of
talk about what MIT with humanities
means at MIT and mumble something like
you know you don't believe you wouldn't
believe it but there's some actually
some decent humanities courses at MIT I
even know some people who major in it of
course if you really don't want to take
these courses you can take them at
Harvard and that's the first message
that most students get when they come
here and their parents get when they
come here about what humanities does at
MIT and it's a deeply troubling message
because it sells short the
accomplishments of an extraordinary
faculty that I was able to be part of
for 20 years who have expertise and a
wide array of different things but to
think so it's a structure of disciplines
that is structured to our disadvantage
as humanities people at MIT and we
struggle with we grapple with trying to
figure out how we fit how we
in this place and again that breeds both
love and hate it breeds both celebration
and frustration on a daily basis as you
try to figure out what it is to function
in such an environment and at the root
of that is this question of
disciplinarity and multidisciplinarity
right and I'm someone who struggled most
of my career with a notion of a
discipline you know because I get the
idea that a discipline functions as a
home base as a foundation as a grounding
body of knowledge as a set of texts you
return to and learn new things from but
I also worry about the verb form of
discipline to be disciplined to be told
what to think and who to talk to and
what subjects are we're studying and
which ones are not and that struggle
with disciplinarity is I think at the
roots of much of the pain and triumph
that I felt at various moments during my
time at MIT because you know I think MIT
did its best shatters disciplines it
opens the way for new kinds of knowledge
it reconfigures fields there's no reason
to believe the disciplines created in
the industrial age are going to be
adequate to the information age it
doesn't mean the contents of those
disciplines should be discarded but it
means they need to be reconfigured on a
regular basis and no place holds more
potential for reconfiguring the
humanities than then MIT as an
institution MIT is also the myth right
which is larger than any of us can
occupy what it is to be the MIT the
brain from MIT the MIT professor is a
myth we step into or we fail to step
into just as our students step into or
fail to step into what it is to be an
MIT student and that's struggle to try
to understand what it is to be someone
who could save the world with your
laptop you know is is sort of part of
the part of the texture of what it is to
be at MIT and what our students who've
been valedictorians and get there first
see crumpled under the gap between their
own abilities and the myth it's what
drives us to be you know to be oh I'm
workaholics almost across the board as
faculty at MIT because we never feel
adequate to MIT you know and and enough
I was honored when I came as a union
junior faculty member to be named one of
the
doc Edgerton professors and MIT and it's
something that I will wear with pride
for the rest of my life and it's sort of
that message for me not only was he
incredible educator an incredible
scientist but in my mind he was
incredible media scholar and media
artist which said to me at a very early
point in my stay that we belong here
that we are part of MIT and that media
and the tradition of media is
fundamental to the way this place works
it's fundamental as Doc Edgerton and
Vandiver Bush are to the history of the
Institute now the young MIT is for me
was also a community and his community
there were so many communities I belong
to and it's amazing to look out through
this audience and it feels a bit like
the end of eight and a half for all the
people in my life come parading behind
and sort of surreal combinations but one
of the first communities was a narrative
intelligence reading group at at MIT a
group of us who met in the basement of
the Media Lab never authorized by anyone
people read a massive amount of stuff
the technologists and humanists taught
each other and learn from each other and
it's an extraordinary generation of
people who came out of the Media Lab who
were part of my cultural training you
know and and who helped me to think
about technology I came to MIT never
having used the internet before and I
remember coming home and having Amy
Brooklyn set up my email account and
coming back after a summer away and
saying oh my god I got 50 pieces of
email what am I gonna do
and Amy sort of laughing in my face at
said wait and see wait and see but the
narrative intelligence group was a place
where ideas about technology and culture
could be brought together and bounced
off each other and it's in some ways I
spent most of my time here trying to
find my way back I also joined this
extraordinary film and Media Studies
faculty that David Thorburn had helped
to bring together that had people like
Pete Donaldson Marni Marx Edward Turk
Edward Barrett
Jill Barrett first fürstenberg an
incredible group of people who I learned
from and learned with about media as we
thought together about what the future
the field was and there would have been
no comparative Media Studies if I hadn't
looked around and seen all of the
faculty here worked across media that
that's what we had in common that they
were already doing work
there was multidisciplinary in
multimedia and what we hoped was the
comparative Media Studies would be a way
that they could more fully realize the
potentials of that work working together
and the biggest community the most
important community for me in many ways
were senior house right and to live in
an undergraduate dorms for 14 years with
an extraordinary group of students who
are so creative you know it's hard to
even sum it up the mud wrestling jokes
are certainly famous you know that but
and that was sort of us Cynthia and I
getting in the mud literally for the
students which we had to do figuratively
and literally many times in the course
of her time at senior house but I
remember with great passion the
creativity of the dorm the sort of
unexpected creativity of the dorm I
remember one night about 2:00 a.m. being
woken up by strange voice you know it's
crowd sounds in the courtyard and
strange bangings and coming down oh my
god what is going on down there and will
they wake up the president who's next
door to us you know and so something and
I threw on clothes and raced down there
and there was a Polynesian dance troupe
performing in the courtyard at 2:00 a.m.
I've seen your house and like not what I
expected you know my first speaking of
students with books in their dorms my
first year as a house master staying up
late at night early near the end of the
fall semester with a group of students
who were reading Dickens A Christmas
Carol aloud to each other was an
incredible memory that I will never
forget about the culture of my of MIT so
that so the community is very much part
of it the process having left MIT what I
see the seeds even more clearly or the
two most precious parts of MIT culture
the Europe and I ap and we underestimate
those at our own peril because they're
fundamental the way this place works
that Europe got undergraduates working
in labs contributing actively to
research being part of a lab culture
that it works at every level because the
undergraduates are there and because
they bring that imagination in the lab
and other universities don't have that
right and I'm pushing at USC to create
something that builds off that Europe
system an IEP does some almost the
opposite it says there's knowledge that
doesn't fit within the column there's
knowledge and ways of learning and
things we want to do that there's no
time for during the semester
let's have a month to explore that to
experiment the play with learning in new
ways and new configurations and so much
great stuff comes out of that process
for me MIT has also been a dream and
that dream is comparative Media Studies
more than anything else the dream that
William and I built together and it was
a shared dream or should we say a mutual
elucidation right and it's a sure dream
with many of you in this room and you
know I'm the one up here at the podium
speaking but William deserves every bit
as much credit for what CMS has done
through the last 10 years I was the
Thunder and he was the lightning and we
were together every step of the way and
that dream at the heart of it was this
notion of the contradictions and the
connections between the words applied
and Humanities and I think sometimes
humanists here heard the word applied
and thought it was a criticism of them
it was simply an observation that caught
the humanities has knowledge that is
fundamental to everything else that's
taking place around this that in a
moment of profound change media impacts
every aspect of our society and for us
the cynic and the Academy and not share
that knowledge not roll up our sleeves
and work would be to fail to meet the
challenge of our generation that to be
an applied field in humanities is not to
say you all humanities isn't applied but
there's special application
opportunities for applied learning now
that we have to take advantage of and
that is the fundamental dream of this
place but it also matters it's a
humanities right that we bring history
we bring culture we bring that whole
tradition with us as we engage with
those challenges and we don't turn our
back on criticism we don't turn our back
from asking the hard questions we engage
with the world from a humanist
perspective and that's the heart of what
I thought CMS was about and what I think
we've achieved at our very best over the
10 years of this program has been in
operation it's also though a bureaucracy
right and the bureaucracy often crushes
rather constrains rather than sustains
the dreams and hopes that we bring to it
it often you know there was a was a
t-shirt at stair roast some years ago
that's an only liability can kill
and when the university becomes so
preoccupied reliability that it loses
the chance the willingness to take risk
to experiment to explore to play to make
mistakes to fail then something goes out
of the life of the Institute and so the
threat is always how can we use the
bureaucracy to sustain and enable the
dreams of its students and it's faculty
and its staff rather than to crush them
and that's a question I think we all
those of you who are at MIT have to
struggle with and you have to think
about what does that mean how do we
build that I think about one of the most
amazing things that come out of MIT came
out of out of the basement of the old
building 20 the Model Railroad Club at
MIT built the first computer game it
wasn't done officially they were
probably breaking a lot of rules using
the mainframe computer to build space
Wars but they did it and it changed the
world yet it always bugs me that there's
nothing in the new building than your
Frank Gehry building commemorating -
that is the birthplace of computer games
because it took place in the basement
like the narrative intelligent group
like a lot of good things happen in the
basements around here and it isn't on
the wall it's not carved in and we
should remember that playing with
technology is how you learn and how you
grow I think of this also as a
crossroads for me right across roads in
the sense at the beginning of my career
when I came out of grad school I there
was a side of me that was deeply
invested in film history and would have
been a traditional historian there's a
side of me that was interested in
cultural studies and fans and
communities and beginning to be
interested in technologies and I was up
for two jobs one of the Rochester where
the George Eastman House is the other at
MIT and the Dean froze the job at
Rochester and somewhat reluctantly I
came to MIT and I think of that as the
moment that my life changed right that
everything I've done for the last 20
years has been shaped in one way or
another by the fact that I have been at
MIT that I was of MIT that MIT got
underneath my skin and became a part of
who I was and I would have been a
totally different person if I had ended
up in Rochester and a certain point I
you know I started to think well who
would I be if I ended up someplace else
what does that road not taken' and so
you know David Thorburn said nicely the
place would not be the same without me
and that
flattery but often as I announced I was
leaving as people said I can't imagine
you any place other than MIT and that
was not flattering to me because it
meant you know I mean there's only one
place I belong there's only one place I
can fit in you know and I sort of said
well I can imagine myself other places
that have been MIT and I can imagine me
doing other things and what I've done at
MIT and like Captain Kirk I want to go
out there and see what that is and see
what that opportunity looks like and to
explore and enable new opportunities for
new kinds of learners and that's really
at the end of the day what this is about
I spent 20 years at MIT during the
digital revolution the most transforming
moment in their society and now I have
the potential to spend 20 years in
Hollywood and during the transmedia
revolution that is going to change how
we tell stories and how we experience
them and that's really powerful for me
so when I arrived at USC one of my
former MIT students who's now at at USC
gave Cynthia and I a gift it was a
beaver with a Trojan scarf and that was
it I keep that next to my desk and it
tells me that I am still a beaver I will
always be a beaver but I'm also a Trojan
now right the diamond I have a hybrid
identity I'm capable of being more than
one person I am altitudes and that sense
of bringing that identity with me is
fundamental to thinking about the
experience of MIT and what it's given to
me and so many others here we always
carried with us I don't have the brass
rap I don't have the ring but I am carry
that beaver with me as a mark of Who I
am the scars and the tattoos of I hate
this place now you are still
here and you face the challenge of how
do you preserve what is best about MIT
how do you protect the creativity from
the bureaucracy how do you protect the
community from the from the liability
how do you define a space for yourself
here that holds together what is most
vital and most important about MIT
culture and MIT students and MIT faculty
and I don't envy you that challenge
these are difficult times for America
and for MIT on a variety of levels so I
hope you will continue to fight the
battle I hope for you the phrase I hate
this place Tillis
with pleasure as well as pain with
optimism as well as despair with you
know at the end of the day you can count
and say there's still one more thing I
found today I loved about MIT and one
more thing I found today I hate about it
it's a good day let's keep going
thank you great to hear you would
actually get Henry really great yeah
it's a hard thing to discuss because
we've one of the weird things with our
relationship is the stylistic difference
you know I'm a historian Henry's really
engaged in the present I'm really euro
focused and Henry's totally American
focused and you would think with all
those sort of profound differences it
wouldn't work and it worked brilliantly
and somehow we would finish one another
sentences or it's so it's a little hard
to interview it's like talking to
yourself so I think I'm going to start
off with something that I don't know a
lot about I mean I know about in a way
but this was your first job after grad
school and you went to Madison and you
worked with two luminaries in the field
at that time who worked in totally
different ways but I don't think
intersected very well as individuals
although I don't know one was David
Bordwell a you know and fantastic
scholar really the benchmark of high end
scholarship in in film studies to this
day I think his work is superb and John
Fiske who really forged new ground and
thinking about popular culture the
empowerment of the not just a fan but
the reader the the the the the
participate the participation side of
the media equation and you worked with
both of these these luminaries and and
I'd love to know more about what lessons
you learned what what came from that
with you to in your baggage to to MIT
what helped you to make this commuter
scholar you are process John
John Fiske retired a little over ten
years ago from the field really walked
away literally gave his books away out
of his library students
grocery bags and took his books and he
moved to Vermont to run an antique store
so I mean it's about as emphatically
accident this year at Madison is holding
an event called fiscal matters it's an
honor of John and he's appearing
academically for the first time in more
than a decade and in getting ready for
it route lidge's reprinting his books
from the 80s and 90s and I was asked
honored to be asked to write the general
introduction to fist work which meant
going back and rereading all the things
that I had that he had written over the
time that I was a student first in Iowa
and then at Wisconsin and discovering
how many strands there were of my own
work that I had thought was totally my
own that I had acquired through him the
ways in which a framework and a ways of
thinking shaped my the trajectory of my
work in profound ways and stuff that I'd
completely forgotten about in his work
still speaks to me and speaks in really
powerful ways about what the field was I
had been a fan and I ended up in grad
school at a time that was particularly
pessimistic and particularly negative
about the role of the audience and the
potential of our processing of media
media was the enemy for most people in
Media Studies at that time and John had
a more optimistic side he believed in
people the power of the public you know
he said that you know every activity we
do as human beings mean something we may
not understand what it means to another
person well we have to get underneath
this we have to get deep enough into it
that we understand its meaning and its
significance and then it looks then
something powerful emerges from that
process and dialogue and that was
something I think that left a very deep
mark on me but reading fist now what I
also see is the pessimism and FISC which
you know no one talks about everyone
thoughts today stacks as if he's a naive
optimist but he you know one of the
things he said about new media at the
end of his write his career writing was
his two things that stuck in my mind one
was keep people here talked about
universal access to computing he said
that everyone in the Middle Ages had Al
Aaron X but not all of them were able to
speak and that was a pretty interesting
comment that having the technology
wasn't enough and and the other thing he
said was new media constitute
a space for struggle new opportunities
for struggle he said and that I think is
something we don't talk about enough
here in particular not that the promise
of new technology but the new
opportunities to struggle over social
justice and cultural equality of a
diversity over inclusion those struggles
are real and struggles about power still
matter and now that I carried with me
but it sort of got pushed down by my
excitement over the agency of audiences
and over the discovery of meaning in
unexpected places now Bordwell was more
of the aesthetic right board well-loved
style and was interested in really
understanding the form of media how
media constitutes an expressive function
but for Bordwell style is not separable
from industry right it wasn't there's
culture and there's commerce those are
completely into wine how media is
produced is fundamental to understanding
the meaning and the style that emerges
from that media and so the idea that we
could break it off industry and only
focus on culture would be strange to me
coming out of that background and so
what David taught me to do was look for
style in the most unlikely spaces and
there are things I wrote about video
games and things I wrote about
professional wrestling and whatnot where
I looked at them as aesthetic objects
and that was still David's voice
speaking through me and sort of still
his influence on me down to the present
day the stuff I do in comics now would
not have been done without David
Bordwell
influence on my on my work there's
another name another figure in the field
long since departed but Howard Rheingold
on the back cover of convergence culture
talks about you as the the Marshall
McLuhan of our age and I know that in
terms of sort of philosophies of media
you couldn't be a farther ends of the
spectrum from a kind of technological
determinist or at least a soft one in a
way but there is some truth to that in
the sense that if I think of terms like
convergence culture or spread ability or
transmedia words that capture dynamics
words that have caught on like wildfire
in both the academic field and the
industry there's a sense in which that's
something that McLuhan is probably the
only other figure I know of in the
Academy who was able to to do that and I
know when you're in your Theory class
you always used the
McLuhan interview in Playboy magazine
I'm just wonder what is that yeah I mean
I don't think like McLuhan but I glue in
was a role model for me in a lot of ways
so Howard is not wrong to make the
analogy although I'm humbled by that
that analogy I don't think there is a
Marshall McLuhan for the 21st century
because Marshall McLuhan spoke in a
moment when there were no other media
scholars in the public domain and so we
could speak as the voice of a whole
discipline and no one could do that
today right and that's but what I
learned from looking at McLuhan x' life
was that he was someone who took his
intellectual ideas wherever they led him
who was utterly fearless and pursuing
his analysis where we took him and that
meant to Nuuanu in unexpected places he
consulted with political candidates he
Swint and spoke and corporate boardrooms
he was involved in our collaborations
with artists like Buckminster Fuller you
know that he he he chose to communicate
with the public in really interesting
ways one of the things you discover was
he issued records every month to
subscribers right so he put his ideas
into what we would now think of his
podcast right and he wrote he wrote
newsletters when he wasn't recording the
records that he's put his ideas down in
prose to send out to the world like a
blog and so I think it's a model of a
public intellectual McLuhan is probably
as good as you're gonna get and that's
why teaching in Playboy magazine
what other theorists can you think of
you know who's ended up in play media
theorists his end up in Playboy magazine
in the interview section what other
theorists gets a gag sequence in Woodie
halls you know Woody Allen's Annie Hall
who got a joke on laughing you know that
maybe Lawrence Lessig it's a character
named after him on the West Wing
that's a kind of monument but the the
end of the greeter which McLuhan entered
pushed his ideas out to the public
through every available channel is
something that I think academics should
learn from and we are at a moment now
McLuhan didn't win his heart right when
you had to record an album on vinyl in
order to do this now we have podcast and
it's easy he did it when you had to
print it a mimeograph and send it out to
the world now we can do it on the
computer and it's easy so you know my
commitment to blogging to the webcast
we've done through CMS really reflects
that vision
how do we do it now how does the key
academic world continue to communicate
with people beyond the University and
all different disciplines and how and
not just how does it speak but how does
it listen and that's that's the the
essence of what I think an intellectual
is in the 21st century and it's what
McLuhan did before any of us
so just to continue that I mean you took
it during your comments you talked about
the need for academics to speak the
language in a language the world can
hear and certainly that speaks to the
issue of public intellectualism but your
background I mean your first degree is
in journalism at Iowa I think you were
or was it in Georgia is journalism yes
and you worked as a journalist for a
while for a very short while or maybe a
very long while I mean maybe well it
fends on how we define our terms ya know
it's very funny to me I'm now at the you
know in the one of my parts of my title
as journalism so I'm back at the and the
journalism school at USC and at the seat
at the table or Pulitzer Prize of
running journalist from the Washington
Post in The Wall Street Journal and
people say well what paper did you write
for and it's a Smyrna Georgia neighbor
news so you know I was an award-winning
high school journalist in college and
won awards in college but after that my
I worked I lasted six weeks of the
degree at that Smyrna Georgia neighbor
news so talks about how pleased he was
that you were you were hired in
literature given this kind of eclectic
background at least has read through the
lens of traditional literary studies and
so what was that what was the tenure
dance like for someone who was at a
pretty early stage of the game a public
intellectual someone who was always
speaking to multiple constituencies hey
you did the requisite academic work and
in spades was that was that was was that
your construction that got you through
or what's the other stuff well I knows
what happens in closed doors around
tenure is a mysterious process and the
scariest part is your entire life is in
someone else's hands to argue about your
work but my philosophy was always if
you're highly productive you usually
you're not going to in any bumps and so
I wrote what I wanted from the junior
forward and I just wrote a lot of it and
I wrote and I was lucky that some of my
early work had inflow
and had been bounced I was careful about
building my reputation I mean I was
probably one of the first academics to
built my reputation via online
communities right that that when I first
got out of grad school in the stereo
mighty and went on the internet I
discovered that there were more people
participating in the film studies
mailing list then the subscription rated
probably all of the top filtered studies
journals combined right if you want it
if you said smart things there on a
daily basis you probably made your
reputation as better than publishing a
couple of peer-reviewed articles in in
journals you also could destroy it and
there were plenty of people in my
generation who just act like like
and destroyed the reputation
you know really quickly and went down in
flames but I didn't and so by the time
my first book came out it was read by a
lot of people it had more readership
than the average first walk by an
academic and from there it was just
about pursuing opportunities and
accepting thinking you know people phone
would ring and I'd say yes to something
that I never imagined doing before and
your youth tremble in your boots and
you'd go on and do it because that's
what it is to be at MIT and getting the
call to come testify before the US
Senate Commerce Committee after
Columbine it's like I said to Cynthia
after I'm gonna I should have my head
examined that I just said yes to this
this is a totally thankless job but it
built the public side of my reputation
in really powerful ways and there's
still people who follow in my career
ever since that and what it felt at the
time like a deeply humiliating
experience turned out to be the opening
for other things and so when I talked to
junior colleagues the advice I have is
take take the unexpected risk take
advantage of opportunities be
programmatic understand your body work
what questions you're pursuing
but veer off it enough that you're
calling in contact with new publics and
new ideas on a regular basis so this
speaks to the issue of sort of a
language people can can hear and make
sense of and to reach but there's also a
bit of farming a bit there's a lot of
fire and passion behind it there's a lot
of commitment David's letters spoke as
David snow spoke about these these
marginalized publics that you've been
really you know wonderful in terms of
empowering does that come from the
project of cultural studies that does
that come from the sort of advocacy
journalism
that come from a the upbringing is a
good good old Southern Baptist what word
is that where does that define I said
we're revealing all of my sources here
so you know I mean there's a lot of that
right that first of all I am southern
and was raised Southern Baptist and so
people always say we don't have a
southern accent and my usual response is
that I don't speak with a southern
accent I just write with one and I think
it's true right that the writing style
that I write comes out of the tradition
of Southern Arts and Letters it's
informal its down-to-earth its pragmatic
its hasn't storytelling impulse behind
it and that's really important to me and
when I'm up there like I was just a
minute ago the cadences of the Southern
Baptist traditions start to take over
and that was a bit of a sermon I'm
afraid but it you know and and I and I
don't the content it starts to fade but
the rhythms of being raised in a
Southern Baptist tradition really comes
through at moments of passion and you
can pour it pour it on when you need to
do it my father ran a construction
company right and he was a deeply
pragmatic person and he and he see but
he valued everyone who worked for them
and everyone he worked with and insisted
on being taken seriously ended up his
career working for the Georgia Board of
Regents supervising construction for and
physical plant for the university system
and he was deeply frustrated by the fact
that because he didn't have a PhD he
couldn't advance to the level that he
might have that his capabilities would
carry him and so that sense of not over
valuing the PhD of knowing that
knowledge comes from many different
places is fundamental to the way we
thought about CMS that we had things to
learn from industry it's not we were
going to go in and teach them he said
there are things they understood about
the present moment of media change that
we needed to hear
thomas mclaughlin talks about vernacular
theory the theory of people outside the
academy
i don't make a split between academic
theory and vernacular theory but I
accept his core premise that all of us
make theories that make sense of a world
that's changing and if we can learn from
each other's theories we can get
insights from each other and that was
the essence of the colloquium
programming that we did together when I
was here was bringing those various
voices together so our students could
hear them
and we thought our vision was that we've
trained out of masters program at 40%
would go on to PhDs and the other 60%
would go to other jobs that we were
training non intellectuals not academics
we were training thought leaders who
which shall be share I have the ability
to communicate their ideas effectively
in whatever context they found
themselves and to be asking the
long-term hard questions that companies
usually don't allow themselves to ask
and that that was more than anything
else looking back over the last 10 years
the legacy of CMS is we've created
thought leaders for industry for
education for EdTech for games for
advertising for museum curator ships for
journalism for Policy think tanks and we
taught them side by side but what we
taught them was to respect and listen to
each other and so you leave people say
about Sloane your best valuable thing is
the rolodex we now those guys are
connected to each other across fields
across professions the powerful network
we created here will continue to
strengthen over the next decades and it
will change and that's gonna that's the
biggest force that will make a
difference in society he's not an
individual mind we trained put all of
those minds together and the connections
they have between them there's the most
vital thing that any of them could have
gotten out of this place and that means
being capable of communicating across
the silos we put ourselves in and I just
say the thing each year that was really
the high point at least for me the high
point of the year was the admissions
process sifting through 100-plus
applicants to find the right 10 people
the mix it was always the mix and it
really I always felt like the students
taught one another not even taught but
the encounters that our students have
had with one another was really as every
bit as important probably more important
than the stuff we did in the classroom
it was really at the mix it's all about
the mix that's the secret sauce one of
the things when we were starting off I
mean an analogy you used a lot it hadn't
heard of before and it was such an apt
one that I'll bring it up because it
speaks to this idea of reaching out
across communities of bringing in
different constituencies and and really
the the core the core logic of CMS was
the recipe for Stone Soup how do you
make Stone Soup yeah and so this was
this is an old children's fable right
the the man who says I'm going to teach
the town how
make Stone Soup and says the one person
all United you is you bring some lettuce
um you bring some carrot you bring some
celery you bring some radishes you bring
some potatoes we're gonna chop them all
up and put my skin my stone put them in
the pot for the stone and we cook it up
and we got a soup and it was you know
it's sometimes call it the Andy Hardy
principle you know I've got we've got
Kyle I've got costumes you've got a barn
let's put on a show that the parts are
here right the parts aren't scattered
across the Institute apart across the
School of Humanities its connections
with every other part of Institute the
parts are here can we put them together
to create something that none of us
could make by ourselves it's the essence
of collective intelligence in a way that
if you bring all these down ingredients
together and so that was the pitch that
we made across the school when we were
building comparative Media Studies was
we don't have a Media Studies program in
the humanities at MIT we have scattered
people and multiple disciplines who were
doing interesting work that could be put
together in a way that allows the cook
something we couldn't cook by ourselves
and can we put those pieces together in
a way that there was something came out
of it and can we put it together in the
heat of MIT because one of the things I
always think back on was a turning point
for CMS was we were in front of one of
the last were Hugh's talking about
proving the Masters you know needless to
say there were not a lot of humanities
faculty in that review body right and
they said you keep talking about a
master's now do you mean a Master of
Science or do you mean a Masters of Arts
and no one had ever asked that at any
level all of us in the school had
thought of course Master of Arts that's
what we all had and he said now before
you answer that know that you'd have to
rewrite the charter of MIT to be Elma
master give a Master of Arts and I said
oh we've always wanted to be master of
science right and then so the sex thing
was well what does that mean right and
so we had to go back and think what does
that mean to be a master of science and
media and we said it's because we're
combining theory and practice we're
combining making and thinking which is
the essence of MIT right that we if we
can put together the skills and making
things and thinking about things in a
way that are mutually governing and
shaping something amazing will come out
and so having our students not just take
workshop courses that taught them skills
when
and research activities that require
them to put those skills in action to
toward real-world problems was the heart
of what made CMS work that was that was
the combination that that made it really
work for students was that ability to
combine theory and practice together in
new ways and weird from steering after
student while I could go to this school
if I want to do practice I go to this
school if I want to do theory and
frankly they're places at MIT right now
that just want to make things
it's just tinkered make things we're
gonna play things we throw them out to
the world and let the world figure out
what they're good for and I can respect
the technical skill of that but I don't
respect the impulse because to me you
make things for people you make things
to do things and a common theory
governing practice is a fundamental part
of the way we think about things and I'm
not sure that everyone in MIT
necessarily always comes around to that
and I think it's something we built into
the program the stuff we did was
humanistic to the core it was also
applied it you know I remember steve's
Tapscott years ago at the inauguration
of Chuck vest read a poem in which he
talked about the two figures on the MIT
ski steel the humanists and the
technologists right have their backs to
each other and that was a really
interesting statement about MIT culture
and what we tried to do for a brief
period of time was get them to turn
around and talk to each other and it's
hard in every direction but if they talk
to each other there's something comes
out of it again that's more powerful
than each of them going off and doing
their own thing and so yeah Stone Soup
is you know key to how we built what we
build in CMS we had no resources we
built something by combining what was
here and convincing everyone is in their
best interest to put their potatoes and
their carrots into the pot it's funny
when you look back at the history of the
Institute I'm sure many people have many
views about the moment that made MIT and
from my perspective it's when the rad
lab was really at working at full steam
back in the late 30s early 40s preparing
for war but it was a completely
interdisciplinary mix a mix of theory
and practice something always applied as
well as thoughtful but it's that robust
interdisciplinarity that yielded so much
that really just yielded so much of the
technology that we now take for
and of course they did it with a lot of
money thanks to Vannevar Bush and we did
it with water and n stones one of the
things that struck reading through
monkford has a really great collection
of the writings of that period all the
way to the present and term his new
media reader and there's a passage in
there from some of the people of that
generation that we're dealing with the
reality that is an academic as a
professor they had an obligation to
profess right that the obligations
professes the obligation to speak the
truth to the world and when they entered
in the rad lab they were entering into a
world of the military-industrial complex
which had certain things had to be
secret and the contradictions of
struggling with that choice are there
things that have to be secret or other
things we are obligated to say they went
into her the greatest of patriotism but
also with a great deal of reluctance
over the secrecy that was build into it
and it's a struggle down to the present
day how do we do sponsored research and
profess how do we share what we know
with the world openly and transparently
and provide secrets to companies and
government bodies that want us to
produce knowledge for them and are
willing to pay us for it and that's the
bargain we make right when we accept
money from some outside entity in order
to do the good stuff we want to do for
our students we make a set of deals that
include not being able to profess
everything we know at that point and you
know we've lost I think as an
institution sometimes that ability to
reflect on those choices we now
naturalize them we take them for granted
in humanities there was a certain shock
when we entered into that process
because we that's not the way humanities
works out square but it's part of the
reality of funding education and MIT but
we need to hold on to the idea of what
it is to profess and that obligation
that that generation felt is something
that moved me deeply as I read through
through that that the writing of that
period so just to jump to a very
different topic legacy what do you see
is the legacy your legacy programs
legacy how would you like that I mean
you alluded to some dimensions of it
during your comments but but any I mean
our legacy is you know I think back
about Fiske and the imprint he left on
me and the degree to which I am
fulfilment of his legacy and I know that
the legacy that I fulfilled will be
fulfilled by the students you know
they're what kept me here and they what
will allow me long after I'm in
retirement to still feel like I had an
impact in the world whether the students
who came through the dorm or the
students who came through the program
they were people that I had some impact
on and I don't say that he kissed achill
II I just know you know that's what you
do it for that's why you teach you know
that you teach because your students
will do things you would not be capable
of doing yourself they're gonna take
your ideas further than you're ever
gonna be take them in your own lifetime
and so first that's the legacy more than
anything else that we graduated almost a
hundred students through the CMS program
over the last decade that's
extraordinary
that we we didn't when I was in grad
school we was a demolition derby and we
lost like half of the students along the
way and our ability to get our students
through the program and get them on
their way and if you look at this
they're sure and what our students are
doing today that's what fills my heart
with pride that's what it's for
everything else yeah I promoted some
ideas transmedia you mentioned earlier
I'm bursting with pride right now that
the Hollywood the producers guild in
Hollywood just created a job title as
transmedia producer right this is a word
I coined and it's now a job category in
the Hollywood system the federal
government Department of Education just
issued a massive call for research on
transmedia education the Canadian filled
board has announced that transmedia that
every project funded by the Canadian
film board will have a transmedia
component and the European community has
been doing the same this was a
conversation I didn't create the
conversation I recognized because we
were listening to industry and we're
engaged in discussions with people on
the field who were grappling with issues
on the ground and we heard the faint
tinkering of stuff and we put into words
and we described it and that empowered
other people to reflect on it and part
of what I was trying to do was move it
from a purely economic question you know
we have Corazon Eliminator integration
in the media industry which means media
is gonna flow across media channels to
an artistic question what opportunities
does it open for human expression how
can we keep more meaningful works in
that car
and the people who took that and carried
and have been part of it the people in
dialog we've had through the futures of
entertainment conference and elsewhere
have been people who were artists who
wanted to tell new kinds of stories and
saw the opportunity of a new media
environment to tell them and the things
that have happened were their success in
the end of building something that
achieved that dream and it's still a
long way from being fully realized it's
a set of experimental work still but
it's experimental works with in popular
culture that's driven by aesthetic goals
that happen to be coupled with economic
opportunities because that's what you do
when you're in an industry you've got to
take advantage of the economic
opportunities if you if you've run
against them you're not going to get
anywhere but if you take advantage of
them and build something exciting then
the culture grows and so that's one of
the legs and the other is the new media
literacies movement which I don't take
credit for lots of people were doing it
but again it was a conversation when I
was in school the last thing you wanted
to do as a media scholar was talk about
education you didn't talk about media
literacy no one Syria at a serious Media
Studies program did anything about media
literacy I mean it was the bottom of the
totem pole but as I run along and
because of the opportunities that we
created through CMS and I got into
conversations I discovered the people in
education returning to cultural studies
to media studies and asking new
questions that pushed our field forward
and I reached out to people like Curt
Squire and Jim James Paul G and engaged
in dialogue and out of that we became
tied to this MacArthur initiative
digital median learning and it's gaining
momentum and it's having an impact on
schools all over the United States it
essentially looks at the kind of
informal learning that takes place in
popular culture communities and said how
can we change the institutions of
Education the museums of libraries to
reflect kids the way kids are learning
outside of school and that's a powerful
legacy of what we helped build at MIT
that we were part of the early push for
educational games we've been part of the
early pushed for new media literacies
we've been part of the early push to
think creatively about the interface of
industry and the consumer we've been
part of the early push for transmedia
entertainment these ideas have had an
impact over the last decade because of
those of us in this room have done
we didn't do it alone but we were Center
for it at every step along the way and
we should all be proud as a community of
what we created with that stuff that's
our legacy not my legacy our legacy as
as a population so now you're in
California and I have to say when I see
you look about a thousand times more
relaxed and pleased to see you around
here with a little bit of a glow from
the Sun I guess you're working with
really different elements in the
industry now right when went on the East
Coast we tend to have the analysts we'd
have to we have the sort of business
guys that development the strategists
West Coast I imagine I mean you work
with them but I imagine if what more
creatives a lot more producer types is
that changing the kind of conversations
you're having is it changing some of
your thinking how has that shift in your
in your you know interlocutors yeah a
lot going on there you know I first
arrived at one of my first the first day
of class I'm walking across campus and
something's submerged in a wave of about
200 sorority girls and Sunday and
sundresses and fruity smelling suntan
lotion and long blonde locks almost 201
and said you know I'm not at MIT anymore
I wake up every morning and stand at a
bus stop and one bus goes by going to
Disneyland and the other goes to USC and
I have to decide every morning which bus
I'm getting on you know and but I'm what
I find in his USC is my Disneyland in a
lot of ways I mean it's an extraordinary
playground to be worth Media Studies is
core business of USC
so whatever peripheral experience we may
have had here I used to joke that I was
a walking talking axe oxymoron a
humanist from MIT you know now I as a
media scholar at USC you are and as the
position that being a computer scientist
or an engineer at MIT is that that's
just what it is and I'm and I'm there's
a beautiful balance between theorists
and practitioners in both of the schools
that I'm in Annenberg the journalists
are trying to figure out desperately how
they survive how newspapers survive how
journalism survives and they're
alongside communication theorist and in
the film school their production people
alongside critical theorists involved in
dialogues and both of them are trying to
figure out how to think across media as
they enter the next phase of their work
and so you know I walk into the USC
campus under the sign of Felix the Cat
because if you go to if you go to USC
there's car dealership just outside the
campus where the giant Felix the Cat on
it that dates back to the 1920s and
that's sort of my trickster god that I
bowed to every morning on the way into
the into work I go past that and if I go
to the cinema school the names on the
buildings are Zemeckis Spielberg and
Lucas right and I think about what was
the impact of cinema school on film
right there was a generation that grew
up through the Guild's that knew one
part of the production process well and
next to nothing about the rest of it
that was displaced by generation the
train together in film schools the
technical people and the directors and
the writers trained side-by-side and
they had a shared language and we got
the Spielberg's Lucas's well the next
challenge is how do they get those
people to think across media platforms
and that requires the same thing we
train game designers and comic book
writers and filmmakers and TV producers
and web designers side by side through
the film schools and they develop a
language and vocabulary
skill that's the next generation and
that's the that's the point I can put
pressure so I said I moved from being
part of the digital revolution in MIT
for 20 years to being part of the
transmedia revolution that's affecting
Hollywood inside the school I'm shaping
and by critical dialogue people who will
change the industry and a fund them in a
way and outside the school the industry
is calling me on a regular basis trying
to get me in the talk and think to them
so I'm in and out of Hollywood studios
and production companies and a chance to
really make a difference critically in
terms of how do these people think about
what the stories of the 21st century are
gonna be and I thought that I'm gonna
change Hollywood but I think that
collectively USC can change Hollywood in
a way that MIT changed the digital media
and so to me it's the right place to be
at this moment in my in my career okay
we're gonna open it up for questions so
if you want to ask something please come
to one of the mics and while we're
waiting for folks to get there just an
observation Henry referenced those
blondes and miniskirt and fruity
smelling blondes out there USC but I
read one of his blog posts that was that
made me misty-eyed and it was I think
Henry was as well when he wrote it
and it was about geeks in love at MIT I
think it was a kind of no I think one of
the things I will miss the most about
this place is that wonderful fumbling
awkwardness of geek geeks in for having
their first law right where everyone in
the room recognizes they're in love with
each other well before they figure it
out for themselves because they lack the
social skills to be able to do it you
know and they're kind of awkward ways
they position their bodies in relation
to each other trying to figure out how
the things come together and not being
quite sure you know it's a bit bigger
problem set than most of them face on a
weekly basis you know and I one of my
most vivid memory of senior house and I
won't name names was I was walking
across campus
a guy in pajamas and no top is bicycling
down campus desperately saying do you
know where I can get a condom
and that will be part of what I remember
in value about this place and a deep
level but again living his
undergraduates you see this beautiful
first blush of geeks and love and I have
to say that there's something way too
polished about the USC students to ever
show that side of themselves to anyone I
think so I was making a portrait of Bill
Gates yesterday and so I asked him I'm a
CMS student compared me to studies do
you have any advice and he said to me
well media is a very interesting
industry it's a very high growth at the
moment it's the business models are
changing rapidly but the big challenge
that's coming up is how to compensate
content creators people that actually
make the art what do you think about
that I think that is the biggest
challenge right now and it's not because
I think at the end of the day students
want to start the community servers want
to steal money from artists but I think
we're in a moment of really fundamental
shift in the economics of the media
industry which makes it really hard to
put the pieces back together again
so I years ago read works by EP Thompson
on the moral economy of the British
crowd British mom and he was talking
about peasant risings and he introduced
this idea of moral economy what he
basically said is behind any economic
structure is a moral structure which
people have to rely on in order to do
business with each other that is it's a
way a set of trust a set of reciprocal
relationships which allow commerce to
unfold and during times of dramatic
change in technology and social
structure in economics the moral economy
breaks down and has to be real Aegina
mised
and the different sides make Appeals for
legitimacy in trying to frame what the
new system will look like so we could
see the languages of pirate and
file-sharing for example as two very
different ways of legitimizing a set of
social practices right different moral
values get attached to them so we are at
a moment when all of those changed right
the economics change the technology
changed the cultural system has changed
and we have to put the pieces back
together and again it probably requires
changing the relationship of the artist
to the consumer and it's probably not
that the labels or the studios or the
networks are gonna be able to rebuild
that relationship it's gonna be built
through social ties that artists have
and I see Ian up there and Ian pointing
out to me something interesting when he
talked to his students he said that they
rarely had a moral argument why they
shouldn't steal content but if you
turned it around and ask is there
content you would always pay for there
was an aunt they'd always had an answer
there was something they would pay for
and you build by asking that question
what content will you pay for who will
you pay for content who do you want to
build relationship to and figure that
out from the bottom up but it's right
now everyone's stomped off to the
separate corners and we have a copyright
crisis and we have a fair use crisis and
we have a lot of names thrown around and
I think at the moment you know we use
the word piracy as if it referred to a
moral failure of consumers and at the
end of the day it refers to a business
failure a gap between supply and demand
a gap between what people are willing to
pay and what people are being charged
and until we sort that out and build a
moral system around that then I think
piracy is going to be the order of the
day and artists are going to suffer for
it so you think people okay so you think
we've already hit that point of
explosion and now it's a matter of
putting things back together or do you
think the point of explosion is still
coming I think it all I think we're in a
period of transition where things are
unraveling and things are coming
together right and that's that
negotiation that Thompson
talked about where the structures that
held British society together at a
certain point had to be rethought as a
gateway from feudalism and began to
enter in some another kind of cultural
system and that I think is where we're
at in mass-media terms so Henry you
spoke about interdisciplinarity and
virtues of breaking down these
boundaries between disciplines and also
about MIT and the uniqueness of our
crucible like institution here which
which we're also happy to hear about it
means no one else is suffering quite the
same way
but I thought it would actually be good
to ask given your current position in
California about how if you have just
ideas or general advice about how we
might make connections and have
collaborations across universities and
working with people reaching out to
industry is also something you spoke
about but the idea of cross campus
collaboration it's certainly among
funding agencies it's certainly coming
to the fore and a lot of big projects
are being funded that incorporate
experts of different places but I'm
wondering you know other than of course
we can go take classes at Harvard
instead of taking humanities classes
here but are there other ways that we
can make connections to other places
well I I mean as I travel around the
world when I travel around the world
with MIT is my mailing address I got
offers from institutions all over the
planet that were desperate to work with
us right it's a question of what are we
willing what are you willing to do with
in the MIT context to enable that
collaboration and it means getting out
of your safety zone and engaging with
other their groups of people and lots of
bureaucratic challenges there too doing
that the most you know there are great
collaborations at MIT as with many
places around the world for us in the
humanities though I think it probably
means breaking out of disciplinary silos
I'm on a MacArthur Foundation research
of right now that's looking at youth new
media and civic engagement and it's got
philosophers it's got education
researchers it's got political
scientists
it's got media scholars on and it's got
anthropologist on it and one of the
first things to get the first things to
make it work is we have to acknowledge
what we know and what we don't know we
have to be willing to listen to each
other and accept fundamentally different
kinds of expertise and when I love about
Annenberg right now is that I'm in a
place that has radically different
methodologies existing side by side in
the same department and I've never heard
a single faculty member there say you
shouldn't be doing what you're doing you
shouldn't be studying that that's the
wrong way to do it there's mutual
respect and that's the foundation and
you have to build it in your school and
you have to build it we across fields
and across disciplines you know MIT
kalau a mighty
people collaborating with literature
people elsewhere that's easy but MIT
literature people collaborating with
anthropologists or you know political
scientists is a bit more of a challenge
and I think that's what's needed as the
knot fields of knowledge get
reconfigured during this period of
transition that I think this period of
median transition the use of phrase or
evocative with 'i'm of the CMS tradition
that we are in right now
that if i think of some of our projects
I mean gambit would be a great example
the Singapore MIT gambit game lab where
we work with RISD we work with Berkeley
School of Music but we also work with a
you know I think virtually every
institution of higher education in
Singapore as well I mean that's a c3 has
wound up with a terrific network of
consulting researchers from business
schools to media schools so those have
been for us sort of very instrumental
ways of trying to reach out and work
with other institutions it's been pretty
productive Ian thank you very much I
want to hear more about this transition
from the digital revolution to the
transmedia revolution and I guess one of
the reasons I ask is that I remember are
you saying years ago a little skepticism
about the revolution part of the
equation and so maybe that's probably
not the underscore under that but rather
transmedia I guess what I'm also curious
about though is that people are talking
about social media is in fact the new
revolution and I'm curious how you see
them connected or different or what's
going on there well first of all you're
absolutely right the revolution in this
context as a rhetorical flourish at best
right because we don't media hasn't
brought about revolutions there wasn't a
Twitter revolution in Iran there wasn't
a Twitter revolution and Moldavia there
wasn't a digital revolution in the
United States right these these are
myths that we construct in our moments
of exhilaration or change we construct
myths about radical change and if we
know anything it's a change has been
gradual that culture both races ahead
and and and holds back the future of
technological change the culture you
know the changes we've seen in
technology we're not just about
technology they're about culture and in
many cases the culture was way out in
front and where the technology was
something we don't say at MIT
and enough and in other places we
the development of that
technology and held back its full
potential and I think so the idea
revolution or negotiation is a word I
use a lot we're negotiating between
tensions in a society that bring about
media change and that change has to be
absorbed gradually you can't bring along
people faster than they're ready and so
when we talk about whether it's a
digital revolution of transmedia
revolution or the social media
revolution we're really talking about a
gradual change that suddenly becomes
visible to us it's been building over a
longer period of time so if we you know
we're also shal media revolution the
hunger for social ties to each other is
scarcely new right Alvin Toffler wrote
in future shock in the 1960s that
Americans would have more and more
disposable relationships they wouldn't
know the people across the hall from
them they wouldn't invest in social
relations because they were moving too
often to build those ties that there was
to mobilize Society for us to feel that
sense social connection it didn't mean
was human beings we didn't hunger for
community it meant we didn't know how to
find it and so social media has come in
it serves a deeply felt need in American
culture that we can carry our friendship
networks with us wherever we go and that
they're not in a moat our ties that we
couldn't become deepened we can spend
more to invest more in our relationships
and we can recover things from the past
that we have lost
and so through Twitter through Facebook
I've reconnected with people from high
school and even elementary school that I
never in my wildest dream could I
imagine we'd find each other again
and that connections in some cases are
very vital to me and so that is
transformative
it may not be revolutionary as a model
of how change is taking place but is
transformative and I would argue the
transmedia seems to be transforming some
aspects of the aesthetics of how stories
work in the 21st century in ways we are
still don't know we're in the early days
of putting the pieces together in new
ways reconfiguring them but their
implications for human creativity and
expression and knowledge that excite me
to my core and I want to be part of that
transformation again probably not a
revolution but a transformation and the
way
culture operates Michael hey Henry I'm
happy that things are sunny and less
stressful out west my question is also
about transmedia it's a huge word that's
blowing up especially in Hollywood where
you are and I was just wondering if you
could be a little specific about
wonderful examples you see happening or
going to happen using that word and then
maybe the epitome of the worst use of
that word that you've seen so far in
conversation or in things that have come
out and just a little addendum to now
that you're not at MIT anymore can you
deny or confirm rumors that were using
performance-enhancing drugs during all
that mud wrestling it's seen your house
trust me if I was using
performance-enhancing drugs I would have
been a lot more effective at it I mean I
am a 90-pound weakling who's put on some
weight but you know so it there's no raw
reads here I have to say but know that
the question of what's good and bad I
mean during the time of change we're
still developing an aesthetic criteria
for it I'm not sure there's been any
totally successful transmedia franchise
to date there are moments of brilliance
and moments that are show real
interesting potential at its worst is
when people don't know don't understand
it and see it as just a cynical move to
manufacture more stuff that's loosely
tied in that we buy right and that
that's that's the corrupting side of the
process we're just like putting more
stuff out there and I put the widget on
it and say yeah I hire the intern to
write it and it's more crap you know and
Hollywood press always produced enough
crap that it doesn't need to produce
crap across all media channels right you
know and it's you know it's like the
dung keeps tall enough right if you're
gonna do it do it well and do it
creatively and use it to expand our
understanding and when it's done well it
does a couple of things it creates a
richer world where the story is taking
place and allows us to experience it it
gives us the backstory of character of
the backstory and fills in the gaps and
holes on the cereal in ways that it adds
more drama and intensity to the elements
we've been given in the past
it creates a deeper understanding of the
characters as this and expands with the
range of point of views and perspectives
we get on the story it immerses us in
the world and it immerses us in the
world in a certain way and it allows us
to create and contribute you know and I
think that's that's what excites me
about it as all of us possibilities we
put in our hands as consumers the
ability to put together the information
in new ways and to create and share
things with each other in new ways and
so for me it's not just about what this
industry do it's what this industry and
Nabal us to do and you know all of us
believe however I've always believed
that our culture is going to become more
and more participatory but the terms of
participation are up for grabs and
they're negotiated daily by the Terms of
Service debates and decisions about
creative openings and the ways we think
about the the user-generated content
that's where the struggle over terms of
participation under culture is going to
be fought and transmedia is part of that
and so both if I'm if I care about
diversity an expression and I care about
the right to participate that's the
place you have to put pressure if you're
going to think about the future of media
I have a number of concerns particularly
the the media gap the problems that are
created by the development of new media
but I grew up in Detroit and used to buy
a temptations album and you would
ultimately buy that album with the
intent that you were going to go see the
temptations and when you saw them live
you loved that album that much more or
you saw them live and you were so much
more willing to buy that album because
you had a relationship with the
temptations it seems as there's so much
leaning toward technology now that that
I'm not hearing a lot of conversation
about how is the human element and
humanities being moved forward in this
in this progress because the best way to
get rid of eliminate pirating is is to
create an experience a living experience
that can't be replicated of them by the
human Elam
so my question I guess is where is that
human element being forwarded in a way
that technology enhances it but is not
the primary focus I mean I think I think
that's a key question I would say for me
it was Patti Smith that that sort of had
that experience of reading hearing the
album seeing Patti Smith live and never
hearing that album the same way again
but that combination of the live and the
recorded is a fundamental part of the
world we live in in Japan the media mix
strategy which is sort of one of the
roots of transmedia often leads to the
theater right the theater and live
performance is centrally part of the
circuit anime shows get translated in
the stage shows we are guess we've done
it with animated films and Broadway but
the sense of that being and and stage
show adds to the circuit of the story we
there's something this theater adds to
that experience we're starting to see
that here right I'm interested in you
know alec here CMS has been doing work
on Glee and either the ways in which
Glee has led to a revival of glee clubs
at schools around the country the ways
in which people are going on and
recording their own versions of the
songs they heard on Glee and putting
them out on YouTube means that people
are reporting in their show and their
homes that the Glee going on tour again
may get people the see live performances
that they would not have seen it
otherwise there's and I think that's
part of a process I'm following the rise
of a group called Legion of
extraordinary dancers which is sort of
combine extreme sports and professional
wrestling and comic book superheroes but
most of all they're dancers that can put
the put any dancers I've ever seen the
shame and they draw on the hip-hop the
roots and hip-hop and street dance and
they're going to communities across the
country recruiting kids getting them a
show off their dancing doing they're
going to be doing Slive stage stuff and
they're gonna be doing things on the
Internet and that's a place where I
think the Internet will enhance our
understanding of dance and our
appreciation of dance I'm someone who
never paying attention to dance would
learn how to appreciate a lots of
different kinds of dances on So You
Think You Can Dance and I'm totally
turned it on on the idea of Legion of
extraordinary
dancers and what it could mean to making
an awareness of a kind of physical
performative art that we most Americans
had no exposure to before and changing
what how we think about it making it as
hip and cool as YouTube and Facebook but
as immediate as any live performance has
been before because it's there in the
streets in your neighborhood you know
and you're seeing something you can't
believe your eyes and I think I think
that's that's part of but we've got to
think creatively about it we can't set
theatres over here and technologies over
here it's gonna engage with each other
is I know you you've thought about and
done through your work Ricardo that
that's part of what gives me hope for
this working as I know people like you
so when I first got the announcement for
this talk I started trying to catalog in
my head all the ways that you're writing
and teaching has influenced me and I
still haven't finished the list so I
wanted to say thank you first of all but
I wanted to get you out of reflective
mode and maybe to think a little forward
one of the things that I think is
interesting about you're moving to a
journalism school is that journalism
itself is in this weird transitional
State and I wanted to know if you've
thought about or are thinking about or
planning to do work in the area of what
is what is the transmedia future of
factual storytelling so we're in a we're
in a mode right now where the
traditional means of journalism which is
the newspaper is essentially dying or
dead for the most part you can consider
it a dead medium on the other hand
documentary films are incredibly popular
they're making more money than ever
before is that the future of factual
storytelling I mean who's gonna tell the
next Columbine story is it going to be a
legion of people on Twitter I mean how
is this story how do you see the next
important factual set of stories getting
told I mean it's a good it's a good
question and one that I'm I'm this fall
teaching a course at USC called civic
media which will be taught through the
journalism school but it's intended to
be a crossroads between communications
cinema and journalism as most of my
courses have been and it's inspired in
part or in part by the Civic view
your centrifuge your Civic media we
helped build here at MIT but it's also
inspired by passage and Clay Shirky who
says the world looks different if we ask
what's the future of newspapers or if we
ask what's the future of journalism and
so what I'm trying to do in the course
is go back to roots and say what do we
want journalism to do what are the
functions of journalism what what role
this journey has journalism played in
our lives and then what institutions
have done those functions beyond
newspapers write newspapers are great I
love newspapers but they may not be with
us all the way they may not and then we
certainly will not fulfill all of the
things we want from journalism in the
future so what I hope to do is read
historical stuff pieces of cultural
theory work on civic engagement look at
projects and try to just explore what
does the future of journalism look like
and what what to what degree is it
citizen driven and what degree is it
professionally driven to what degree is
it in digital or what degree is it in
print trying to explore those questions
and I don't know the answers yet I mean
that's what excites me about teaching
the course is I'm pulling a lot of stuff
together I've been wanting to read and
think about and throw an open to a
roomful of PhDs whoever throws future
rests on the answer to this question and
we'll see what we can figure out
together but again like everything I try
to do in the classroom it's about
breaking down borders between
disciplines and between communities and
seeing what we can learn from each other
and ask me the question a year from now
I'll probably have a better set of
answers that I have now I'm just picking
up on you know Facebook was mentioned
briefly and just personally I hate
Facebook
I think there's I just log on and
there's like 10,000 pieces of you know
random tidbits out there that I don't
really care about and there's no tools
to organize it or find what's useful and
I'm just curious I mean I'm there's lots
of people who love it there's lots of
people who who don't use it in what
happens I don't you have any thoughts
about what's the next step maybe in how
Facebook or similar tools might evolve
to reach that audience or is that maybe
I don't know I'm not going to happen or
is that just a big question I mean I
personally don't like Facebook in the
aggregate but I love the individual
encounters that I have on Facebook
that I read same with Twitter right I
read so much banality every morning but
I see so many nuggets of things that I
wouldn't see before that it's to me on
hole worth it but it's gonna continue to
evolve and be redesigned and I think the
question is how do the big question is
how do we create meaningful context how
do we build on the connections we have
and not be drowned not be swamped by the
social networks we participate in and
again I don't know the answer but I
urgently hope we find find it because it
does affect the social life of the world
we live in and how we connect to each
other as human beings I wouldn't trade
some tweets I've gotten for anything in
the world and others I can't believe
they put that in writing right you know
the jokes you're often did I just say
that out loud well more than saying out
loud you just send it out to 5,000
people you know a top academic I know
sent out something about finding dog
poop on the bottom of her shoes and I'm
going why you know I and I understand
the meta communication piece that by
sending banality z' back and forth we
you know we say to each other I'm here i
someone asked me in the McLuhan question
about Twitter and instead of what's them
if medium is a message what's the
message Twitter and my answers was to
message here it is and Here I am that
here it is is all the interesting links
I get and Here I am is the banal
chitchat that says I'm alive and you're
alive and we're in the same world with
each other and those two functions build
on the back of each other in really
profound ways and the result of hearing
through a medium that we use to talk
about what we had for breakfast what's
happening the streets of Tehran gave an
immediacy and and to that experience
made people change the way they thought
about people in I Ron after 20 years or
30 years of Iranians being totally
estranged from us people chose to turn
their face green and create an identity
with Iran it's a trivial gesture
politically except that nothing in the
history of Iranian American relations
over the last 30 years prepares us for
it but the social dynamic of a platform
that we connect through create a space
where it was possible for that to take
place and
that's what leaves me hopeful about
social social networks okay one more
then we're gonna switch over to the
reading of the Cat in the Hat hey Henry
um this question actually just made me
think of something you've spent so much
of your career
theorizing participation and what it
means to participate in a whole variety
of way giving light to all of that now
we get to this interesting point where
we have people who have made a conscious
decision to not participate in all sorts
of different places how do we start
theoretically thinking about non
participation and how that actually
intersects with all of the work that
you've been thinking in terms of
participation well your the right to
remain silent
right and that's it that's a fundamental
right there's human beings the right to
participate includes the right not to
participate but I also we're gonna read
dr. Seuss in a minute and I always think
that the horton hears the who has really
interesting things to say I think about
this issue because it has you know on
the one hand it's about the need to
listen to the smallest of voice in the
society and to amplify it and to ensure
that it gets heard on the other hand
there's a tension in that book between
the Wickersham cousins and brothers and
so forth who force conformity at all
cost and jo-jo the shirker
the smallest of the who's whose war
until he contributes his voice the
entire community can't be heard and so
the tension in the book between what
what it demands can society make on it
some individual members what are our
obligation to contribute and participate
is a fundamental one that I think Zeus
was thinking about in the post-war
period and I think there's a lot to
speak to it in terms of the question
we're thinking about now yes you have
the right not to participate but if you
in a society where we pool our knowledge
and you know things that can change that
has impact on the society do you have
the right to withhold that knowledge or
do you have a certain obligation to what
you know and how you know it and the
community you're part of to speak so
what are our obligations to speak and
what are our rights to remain silent I
think of the fundamental questions we
have to think about and I I don't think
we've spent nearly enough time thinking
about either side of that when it comes
comes to the digital right so just to
say Henry talked about the importance of
IEP
this is really one of the for me high
points of the the I ap each year was
Henry's Henry's reading so we get to do
it offseason and uh last eighteen years
I done the salute to dr. Seuss which is
one of my contributions to the culture
of MIT and we showed 5,000 fingers of
dr. T and and the summer I will be doing
showing that movie as part and being
part of a discussion around it at the
Egyptian theater in downtown Hollywood
so I'm very excited to be part of that
and I thought as a parting words to this
community maybe reading from dr. Seuss
was a was a way of continuing that
tradition in sharing review how much the
light I taken and Seuss is writing and
how much it characterizes to me that
creativity and imagination which is so
vital at MIT and that we turn our back
on at our own peril so the Sun did not
shine it was too wet to play so we sat
in the house all that cold cold wet day
I sat there with Sally we sat there we
to and I said how I wish we had
something to do to wet to go out and to
cold the play ball actually a good day
to read this isn't so we sat in the
house we did nothing at all so all we
could do was to sit sit sit sit and we
did not like it not one little bit and
then something went bump how that bump
made us jump we looked and then we saw
him step in on the mat we looked and we
saw him The Cat in the Hat and he said
to us why do you sit there like that I
know it is wet and the Sun is not sunny
but we have we can have lots of good fun
that is funny I know some good games we
could place at the cap I know some new
tricks at the Cat in the Hat
a lot of good tricks I'll show them to
you your mother will not mind at all if
I do then Sally and I did not know what
to say our mother was out of the house
for the day but our fish said no no make
that cut go away tell that cat in the
hat' you do not want to play
he should not be here he should not be
about he should not be here when your
mother is out now now have no fear have
no fear said the cat my tricks are not
bad said The Cat in the Hat why we can
have lots of good fun if you wish with a
game that I call up up up with a fish
put me down said the fish this is no fun
at all
put me down said the fish I do not wish
to fall
have no fear said the cat I will not let
you fall I will hold you up high as I
stand on a ball with a book on one hand
and a cup on my hat but that's not all
that I can do said the cat
look at me look at me now said the cat
with a cup and a cake on the top of my
hat I can hold up two bucks I can hold
up the fish and a little toy Shep and
some milk on a dish and look I can hop
up hop up and down on the ball but that
is not a wall oh no that is not all look
at me look at me look at me now it is
fun to have fun but you have to know how
I can hold up the cup in the milk and
the cake I can hold up these books and
the fish on a rake I can hold up the toy
Shep and a little toy man and look with
my tail I can haul up a red fan I can
fan with the fan and as I hop on the
ball but that is not all oh no that is
not all that is what the cat said then
he fell on his head he came down with a
bump from up there on the ball and Sally
and I we saw all the things fall and our
fish came down - he fell into a pot he
said do I like this oh no I do not this
is not a good game said our fish is heal
it no I do not like it not one little
bit now look what you did said the fish
to the cat now look at this house look
at this look at that you sank our toy
ship sank it deep in the cake you shook
up our house and you bent our new rake
you should not be here when our mother
is not you get out of this house said
the fish in the pot but I like it here
oh I like it a lot said the cat in the
hat to the fish in the pot I will not go
away I do not wish to go and so said the
cat in the hat so so so I will show you
another good game that I know and then
he ran out and then fast as a fox the
cat
came back in with a box a big redwood
box it was shot with a hook now look at
this trick said the cat take a look and
then he got up on the top with the tip
of his hat I call this game fun in a box
said the cat in this box are two things
I will show to you now you will like
these two things said the cat with a bow
I will pick up the hook you will see
something new two things and I call them
thing one and thing two these things
will not bite you they want to have fun
then out of the box came thing two and
thing one and they ran to as fast they
said how do you do
would you like to shake hands with thing
one and thing two and Sally and I did
not know what to do so we had to shake
hands with thing one and thing two we
shook their two hands but our fish said
no no these things should not be in this
house
make them go they should not be here
when your mother is not put them out put
them out to the fish in the pot have no
fear little fish said the Cat in the Hat
these things are good things and he gave
them a pat they are tame oh so tame
they've come here to play they will give
you some fun on this wet wet wet day now
here is a game that they like said the
cat they like to fly kites said the Cat
in the Hat no not in the house said the
fish in the pot they should not fly
kites in a house they should not all the
things they will bump all the things
they will hit I oh I do not like it not
one little bit then Sally and I saw them
run down the hall we saw those two
things bump their kites on the wall bump
them bump bump down the hall all in the
whole thing to you and thing 1 they ran
up they ran down on the string of one
kite we saw ma mother's new gown her
gown with the dots that are pink white
and red then we saw one kite bump on the
head of her bed then these two things
ran about with big bumps jumps and kicks
and with hops and big thumps and all
kinds of bad tricks and I said I do not
like the way that they play if mother
could see this oh what would she say
then our fish said look look and our
fish shook with fear your mother is on
the way home do you hear or what will
she do to us what will she say oh she
will not like it to find us this way so
do something fast said the fish you hear
I saw her your mother your mother is
near so as fast as you can think of
something to do you have to get rid of
thing 1 and thing 2 so as fast as I
could I went up after I went after my
net and I said with my net I can get
them my bet I bet with my net I'll get
those things yeah then I let down my net
it came down with a plop I had them at
last those two things had to stop then I
said to the cat now you do as I say you
pack up those things and you take them
away oh dear said the cat you did not
like our game oh dear what a shame what
a shame what a shame
then he shot up the things in the box
with a hook and the cat went away with a
sad kind of look that is good said the
fish he's gone away yes but your mother
will come she'll find this big mess in
this mouse is so big and so deep and so
tall we cannot pick it up there's no way
at all and then who was back in the
house where the cat had no fear of this
mess said the Cat in the Hat
I always pick up all playthings and so I
will show you another good trick that I
know then we saw him pick up all the
things that were down he picked up the
cake and the rake and the gallon and the
milk and the strings and the books on
the dish and the cat fan and the cup and
the ship and the fish and he put them
all away
and he said that is that and then he was
gone with a tip of his hat then our
mother came in and she said to us - do
you have any fun did you have any fun
tell me what did you do and Sally and I
did not know what to say should we tell
her the things that went on there that
day should we tell her about it now what
should we do well what would you do if
your mother asked you
so if I have any parting words to this
crowd it is keep on doing fun that is
fun and don't listen to the damn fish
[Applause]
words of wisdom so again just to remind
you folks that tomorrow all day up in
sixth floor of 4014 the new media lab
building will be having a set of
discussions tomorrow and then tomorrow
night at 7:00 a party normally we have a
reception after the communications forum
but it will be displaced until tomorrow
evening seven o'clock and it's
beautifully exquisite so hope you can
join us and please don't forget to pick
up your copies of of the 10th
anniversary newsletter where the
achievements of Henry and CMS and our
students and our researchers and faculty
are all present Henry thanks very much
[Applause]